giant spaceships creepy old women in
triggering my PTSD from high school gym
class
Amazon's the vast of night is a sci-fi
set in the 1950s which asks the question
did cheerleader uniforms really look
like this
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into its ending so connect your
lines because here we go the first thing
you need to know is that we're watching
a TV show within a movie the vast of
night is the name of the episode of a
television program called paradox
theater and homage to the twilight zone
even the narration found in their
introductions are eerily similar and
found only in a frequency cut between
logic and myth it is the middle ground
between light and shadow between science
and superstition and this film plays a
lot with that line between the real and
the imaginary as viewers were never sure
what we're hearing is true or as
characters from this era would say
malarkey later in the film and Everett
talks to Mabel Blanche she hears a
fantastical tale about how her son was
taken by aliens he doesn't believe her
but as we'll find out in the last scene
that will change paradox theater is the
perfect name for the show were about to
watch because in theater there are many
paradoxes like how what we're watching
is real yet simulated the audience's
involved yet remains apart the actors
are themselves yet they are characters
if you rewind a little bit you can make
out how the music creates these
waveforms almost like an oscilloscope
considering how the film revolves around
the radio it's easy to see why the
director chose to start with this image
were introduced to one of the main
characters Everett he runs the local
radio station and is the go-to guy when
anyone at the school seems to have a
problem and that's exactly what has
happened the schools been plagued with
power outages which everyone seems to
blame on a squirrel who chewed through
the electrical line as we'll find out
later there's something more mysterious
at play and for the first 15 minutes or
so the dialogue never stops there's
always someone talking on screen
bombarding us with information about the
people or town that it becomes difficult
to keep up this is a stark contrast to
the final 10 minutes of the film where
there's almost no dialogue at all we
then meet Fay a local switchboard
operator who needs
Everett's help working her new tape
recorder he even walks her to work in
the downtown street is lined up with
these lights that resemble miniature
flying saucers Faye is really into
science and tells Everett about all the
amazing new technology she's read about
in magazines like automated cars that
give directions through the radio vacuum
tubes that can transport people or small
screens people keep on them at all times
to communicate with one another but the
transition to the real meat of the story
happens about 18 minutes in the director
has chosen to show this blinking flying
saucer type image foreshadowing the end
of the film which fades into the
television reminding us that what we're
watching isn't real Faye takes over the
switchboard and starts getting some
unusual calls like one from a woman who
has gone to hide in her cellar after
seeing a large object over her land
which is created tornado like wind then
she hears an unusual sound the New York
Times reported that this sound was
created using a mixture of instruments
human throat noises and mechanical hums
we wanted the sound in particular to be
new in cinema this sound will play a
pivotal role throughout the film as it
will be the one everett airs over the
radio looking for anyone who may know
what it is there's this amazing long
shot that travels all the way from the
switchboard through to the school and
out to Everett's radio station in fact
the camera doesn't cut for almost four
and a half minutes this gives us a sense
of where everything is in relation to
one another since as Mabel later says
the aliens only like to take people who
are alone or away from crowds the
hovering effect of this shot also
implies like we're one of these
spaceships traversing the town in search
of someone new to take a board
Everett receives a phone call from a man
named Billy Billy says he's heard that
sound when he worked for the military
now I have to apologize for the lack of
corresponding visuals here the film
purposely keeps us in the dark when
Billy is explaining his side of the
story
just like how Billy was kept in the dark
about what was really going on at this
top secret base so Billy ends up digging
an enormous hole with his coworkers
which was later filled with a quote
smooth object that looked damaged and it
was covered in a tarp
an object bigger than an airplane all
the clues given to us point that this
object was one of these smaller flying
saucers we see near the end Billy says
it wasn't American Russian or anything
he had seen before this was something
different
Billy was sworn to secrecy about this
mission and told that giving this
information could jeopardize America he
also talks about building ventilation
rooms with see-through glass if indeed
it was a flying saucer in there that
crash-landed on earth it's safe to
assume these ventilation type rooms were
used to study or dissect the alien
creatures on board in fact that may be
why these aliens keep coming back
they're looking for their people and
possibly in retaliation have taken some
of ours if we're performing experiments
on them and taking them against their
will who's to say they aren't doing the
same to us Billy also talks about how he
became sick after a kintu radiation
poisoning this would explain why what he
was building was underground to contain
this radioactive entity Billy tells them
that a friend of his recorded the sound
and mailed it to a bunch of people one
of whom lives in their hometown but he
passed away and his recordings were
donated to the local library
so Fay breaks into the library and
retrieves them allowing Everett to
broadcast the sound in the hopes anyone
else may have heard it that's when they
get a call from Mabel Blanche an old
woman who claims her son was taken by
quote the people in the sky
Mabel tells a fascinating tale about how
as a child there was a woman who
survived a mysterious train accident
where everyone on board disappeared this
woman would say cryptic words in her
sleep the same words she's heard saying
whenever it first enters a way ruffle or
yak a Tillie would that's all now I
tried to see if there was any hidden
meaning to these words I even played it
backwards which you can listen to here
[Music]
but I couldn't find anything and that's
probably the point since if these are
aliens their language is probably
something we can't even comprehend later
Mabel recalls the story of her child
Hollis Hollis his first words were the
same words she heard that mysterious
woman saying to herself in her sleep she
recounts an even stranger story when
Hollis was four he'd stare up at the sky
and when she
repeated those words his lips would move
along with hers something was
communicating with hauless something
only he could hear then at the age of
nine Hollis left out the front door and
disappeared his footprints were found
leading a hundred and fifty feet away
but then they just vanished since then
the townspeople thought Mable killed her
son
but the investigation showed up nothing
Mabel has a theory however she believes
that aliens are controlling us like some
sort of advanced radio they are the ones
that get in our heads the ones that say
we should always clean our house lose
weight or do destructive things on a
greater scale they are the ones that
caused nations to go to war it's a way
of distracting us she says but free will
it's impossible if we're being
controlled and we don't even know it is
there such thing as free will as Everett
and Fay pack up to leave Mabel has one
last request that they take her to the
alien ship so that she can be with her
long-lost son Everett thinks she's crazy
even refusing the paper containing the
mysterious word she was saying earlier
and when Faye in Everett leave we get a
good encapsulation of how different
these two characters are they believes
Mabel could be telling the truth while
Everett is a staunch realist preferring
to believe that these mysterious
occurrences are pointing at a Russian
invasion from Mexico rather than aliens
and this goes back to the very beginning
of the film where we must choose to
travel the path of logic or of myth
logic Everett myth Faye so Faye totally
forgets that her friend Ethel was
supposed to be looking after this baby
so she goes to get her and finds Ethel
missing but will later learn in a phone
call that she was up on the roof
watching what appeared to be a flying
saucer
so Faye gets her camera to take
photographic evidence and teams up with
Everett and two of his friends but
whenever plays those words on the tape
recorder his friends look up into the
sky as if controlled by something this
was the same thing that happened to
Mabel's son Hollis they in Everett - out
of the car and run into the forest where
they come upon a clearing the nearby
trees and ground have been burned and
when they look up into the sky the tree
line has been ripped open it's a bit
hard to see in the dark but you can make
out snapped branches Everett now
believes they're not alone
here they see a flying saucer emerged
making its way up to a ship that looks
about a thousand times bigger that's why
I believe this ship Billy was making
room for on his secret mission was for
one of these smaller saucers and not
this large thing I could only imagine
how big a hole you'd need to dig to fit
that thing underground
you'll also notice in this shot here
Everett and Faye looking up in awe at
the ship I don't believe they're
controlled here as the next scene we see
Everett and Faye embracing as a tornado
like wind seemingly sucks them up into
the ship we earlier heard a woman
described tornado like winds when she
called into the switchboard now we never
see what happened to Faye in Everett the
town goes back to normal the lights turn
back on at the radio station but our
final shot gives us some clues
it starts with footprints in the dirt
and dust that have piled up remember
that Mabel followed footprints to find
her son only to have them lead to
nothing we then see the tape recorder
which has been left behind covered in
dust
the only remnant of Everett and Faye the
fact the recorder was left behind but no
evidence of Everett and face suggests
they were taken much like Hollis was but
why well that's the ambiguity of the
ending we do know these aliens haven't
attacked and they keep a low profile if
they were truly dangerous they'd have
wiped out humanity long ago they are
also clearly far more advanced than us
so who are these aliens are they from
another planet are they us from the
future I will say that this ship does
look like it could have been built from
material on earth regardless the ending
is up to our own interpretation it's
meant to make us think but in the end
the film ends with a reminder that what
we're watching isn't real we're watching
a TV program it's up to us to straddle
that line between logic and myth science
and superstition which one will you
choose thanks everyone for watching
please make sure to give this video a
like and subscribe I'm always coming out
with new content for more bad takes you
can also follow me on twitter at think
story whitey
until next time remember
daddy loves you very much